happy 2021 all right so
it is now officially 2021
and thank you so much for joining me
here today guys
this isn't a video that's going to
explain anything architecture so if
you're on this channel for the first
time firstly my name is david tomic
and thank you for joining me on this
channel we usually talk about
architecture and technology
and how to make you a better architect
along the way but today we're just
celebrating the start of a brand new
year
2020 was an incredible journey for all
of us it is
definitely one that will be remembered
throughout history and be written in the
history books forever
2021 will hopefully be a little bit less
memorable
but hopefully at the same time just as
exciting
with lots of positive things to come so
if you've landed on my video for the
first time thank you so much
if you're a regular here thank you very
very much for joining me on this journey
2021 we're going to step it up a notch
we're going to produce even better
content for you guys
and we're going to continue to bring out
all things architecture and technology
related
so if that's something that interests
you make sure you smash that like button
help this video with the youtube
algorithm
smash that subscribe button because it's
20 21
and as always i will see you next monday